running too far and behind schedule
let's uh
let julio say speak
um sorry
by the way i cannot see you i don't know
oh you cannot see but can you hear me
can you see my screen yeah we can see
your screen just not your face and
maybe that's fine but it's always nice
to see the speaker's face if it's
possible
so i'm not sure how to fix it now okay
that's okay if it's
much of a problem
so yes take it away
okay good uh yeah so thank you thanks a
lot for the introduction and and
really a special thanks for for to blast
for organizing this workshop i think it
has been
for me at least a great learning
experience and
a great way to to support this this
research branch
so today i'm going to give the first the
first part of the talk based on
a circularity based io um and this is
really intended to be the first part of
a unique talk
of a cohesive talk and i'm just going to
give
you know the introduction introduce the
main uh the main
basic idea of the framework and then uh
roman
and daniel will will continue from there
uh explaining more uh more
more specialized construction and
analyzing in the details
uh things so and please i mean this has
been mentioned already but
please interrupt me if something is not
clear i'd be very happy to to make this
an interactive talk
okay and by the way i should mention
that at least from my side this was a
joint work with zwika nico and sanjo
good so what this talk and the
subsequent two talks are going to be
about is of course a new construction a
new candidate construction of
class of construction of
indistinguishability of fuscations
um which have uh three
main uh three main features that i would
like to highlight here
um so the first and and i think the most
important for me
is that the construction are actually
simple to understand like
bearing uh some generic construction
which which are
swiped under the rack but but the new
ideas in this work
you'll see are quite generic and quite
modular
so in particular at least for as far as
our work is concerned they're not
specifically tied to any algebraic
structure and they're quite portable so
i hope that
they might be even useful in other
contexts um
the apps the upside of this of this
generality is that we can
essentially base everything on lw based
techniques
uh and therefore uh conjecture the
post-quantum security of our schemes
um and the assumptions that we are going
to
prove our construction secure against
are relatively simple and some in some
sense
each work will have a different flavor
but in some sense they are all related
to
some some notion of circular security
and for those of you who forgot what
circular security is
that's here on the on the
bottom right side of the slide you can
see an example of a two
key circularity which essentially says
that an encryption switch should stay
secure even though we
encrypt their own key inside of the
instead of the
encryption algorithm and the cycle can
be
generalized naturally to any cycle
length
okay so um just to be on the same page
we are doing the standard notion of
indistinguishability affiliation i
really don't want to spend time on this
because it has been already
discussed at length with the definition
of io but
this is basically what we're doing so we
want another skater for which
for all functional equivalent program
the two observations are computationally
distinguished
so we are doing the same thing as as
everybody else
and this slide is just to show show off
my
artistic talent so we can skip it um
and uh so before before actually talking
about our results i want to give
a classification like or a very personal
classification on the approaches that
have been taken in order to construct io
um so the first approach was
uh was was from started from gargital
from multi-linear maps
um and i want to also highlight some
what like what i consider to be upside
of these approaches and what what are
the less maybe satisfactory aspects of
this approach
um so the the the the i think what's
what's great about this approach is it
has
attracted a lot of attention from the
community and it has received a lot of
cryptanalysis
um which which as somehow increased a
bit our confidence in
the assumptions although many of them
have been broken at least there's been a
lot of work in there
unfortunately we never we never really
got to
reduce the security of those schemes
against like
something which is uh close to a
standard assumption or like
maybe maybe not even a nice to stay
assumption
um the this is motivated like the
the next line of work that started
studied
the possibility to construct legal
starting from functional encryption in
particular from bilinear maps and this
has
come culminated with the with the work
of uh
jalen and sahai which we saw yesterday
and it ended they ended up giving a
construction of io
um from these four assumptions they've
been discussing
so i'm not going to elaborate on those
um the only thing that i want to
highlight here which is
somewhat what distinguishes probably our
of
our approach from this approach is the
fact that they
seemingly inherently rely on uh
the uh on on this sxdh assumption so in
the process of bilinear maps and these
this
automatically disqualifies the uh the
construction from
from claiming both quantum security and
although so although one it's hard to
make formal statement it seems like
really the the compression from their
approach really comes from the presence
of bilinear maps
so as i said it seems quite inherently
tied to
not having post quantum security there
are other approaches perhaps
not as popular to construct io based on
tensor products
uh or find the terminal program and
finally the approach that
that we're going to talk about today is
going to be the approach
based on homework encryption or split
efficiency
in introducing bbgm 28 so in our
favorite euro club last year so this is
going to be the focus of this talk
and as you see the the ideas um
introducing this work were uh are are
quite different from
from the standard multi-linear mass
space or even by linear mass-based io
and are some of the common denominators
between all the results that we're going
to see today
so let me let me give you a quick um a
quick
schematic summary of this approach well
essentially
the the main focus of the approach is to
construct the so-called exponential ios
or xio
and we know by a generic transformation
that this is by itself sufficient to
construct io
assuming additionally and the main
technical tool that this work introduced
was the notion of split fhe which more
or less directly allows you to construct
exile and i'll elaborate a little bit
more on that so just
just believe me for the moment and the
technical hurdle
of this works was essentially to give a
candidate construction of split fhe
and and this first work just gave a
construction starting from
the existence of two building blocks
which is one fully homomorphic
encryption satisfying certain
certain structural properties
together with the um with the dungard
during encryption
and for for technical reason in the
proof they ended up
using something like a random oracle um
so the advantage of this this framework
is that it's
conceptually very simple it's quite easy
to understand again
uh if you if you don't care about the
construction from xio to io
but on the on the downside there was no
uh
no security proof against any you know
self-contained assumptions
and again the uh presence of the
downgrade during encryption
disqualifies this scheme immediately
from claiming post quantum security
because
this uh the security of the dam grand
turk is
intimately related with the ability of
factoring large numbers
okay so what we're going to talk about
today are going to be this
new result that sort of managed to
go above and beyond this work uh and and
present uh construction of xio
uh or or split fsgs we'll we'll see
later
um based exclusively on lwe like crypto
systems
and the while the ideas of these three
works
uh are structurally very very similar so
very related among each other
there are some differences in the
abstraction that they're going to use
and
actually also in the instantiation that
that that that are going to end up in
the in
in the papers um so to give you a very
very rough characterization the uh the
work of
brakers get also the gm20b
and the work of gay pass they uh they
use more of a proxy encryption so an
interplay between
uh between two uh uh two homomorphic
encryption scheme
to give a construction of uh of xio
directly
whereas the work of the work of
wix and we gave a more direct
construction of uh
of this functional encoding which is
essentially a generalized version of
split apic
and i am not going to spend too much
time on this because roman
will explain this at length but the
security of this
of this approach can be proved uh under
a simple
although new assumption and this is this
assumption is very
intimately related with again circular
security as i said before
um and the upside of these approaches is
that
they are going to be at least plausibly
post quantum secure so we don't know of
any trivial attack
using the quantum computer okay is there
any question up to now
if not i'm going to describe a little
bit what what xio is and
give an overview of the framework
of the edm framework so people can feel
free to unmute themselves and ask
questions but
if there are no questions feel free to
continue
okay perfect so what is exponential
xio we already saw this notion at length
but let me repeat it here for
completeness
um so xio is the observation of circuits
uh where the domain of the circuit is
actually a polynomial size
domain so in particular this means that
in polynomial time i can
evaluate this circuit on all possible
inputs and for simplicity we're just
going to assume that the circuit is
going to be a boolean circuit
[Music]
and return zero one and uh
uh besides of course the the uh notion
of security of computation
and distinguishability for equivalent
circuits the only additional
uh condition that we impose on this xio
is that of non-triviality
which essentially says that um the size
of the obfuscated circuit
should be uh sub linear so
a synthetically smaller than the size of
the truth table of c which is
basically so the size of the domain of c
okay and there's a beautiful theorem
from uh
uh from from from the work of the natal
that says that
um uh assuming assuming
xio and the sub exponential arguments of
l w then we
we get obfuscation so this uh this is
great for us this essentially means that
we if you if you
if you're fine with the you know sub
exponential w which i think we are all
fine with this kind of assumption
um then all you need to do is just to
construct
this xl so this is going to make our
life much easier so
for the rest of the talk we're just
going to to care about how to construct
exponential value and by the way
the the theorem even generalizes the
pre-processing settings so what does it
mean the pre-processing
here i'm assuming that in addition to uh
to a description of the circuit c
the author skater is also given access
to a common reference stream
which is which consists of it can be
even a structural distribution as long
as it's
sampled independently from uh from from
the office skater
so it you know this is necessary right i
mean
just in terms of uh compression right
you cannot compress a long
longer string without uh giving more
information
um it's not it's not just a relaxation
right i mean
you you cannot compress an n-bit string
by by shorter sling without putting
adding some information in the
background or maybe so
no so the the point is that you don't
want to compress c you just want to
compress the truth table of c so you're
not looking really for information
theoretically compression you're just
looking for computational compression
it's an indistinguishability-based
notion of security for x-i o so there's
no incompressibility bound if you wanted
simulation the crs would be necessary
but this is an
please no no i'm talking about
correctness forget about forget about
security just correctness
no no penny benny if you have an xco
with a cirrus you can get xco without
the crs
yeah that was my next step but benny i
think
benny's question maybe the question is
the following
when you said n to the one minus epsilon
you also allow
terms that are polynomial in the circuit
size description of c
yes of course oh okay good good yes
okay sorry sorry about that yes yes of
course so
of course you know in order for this to
make sense the uh circuits should have a
compact representation
and i'm allowing yeah i don't care about
the polynomial terms and see
so sorry for the confusion yeah so so
just to make sure what you mean is the
size observation of c
is the size of the circuit plus n to the
one minus epsilon or something
of that form or even pulling the circuit
even policy
yeah paulie in the circuit yes yeah
thank you i think that was benny's
confusion yeah exactly
oh yeah yeah thanks for the question
sorry for the confusion you know of
course
i'm omitting a lot of things here on the
slide
yeah um so
so as i was saying um uh this notion
even works for
for the pre-processing settings so that
means that
we we're having access to a common
reference string and i i'm not really
going to impose
any constraint on the common reference
string besides the fact that is
uniformly sampled and i'm even allowing
the size of the common reference string
to be as long
as the truth table of the function
and here there is actually a pretty easy
transformation that shows that
xio in the common reference string
implies
xio without a comma reference string and
i want to
quickly sketch these transformations of
course not going to be anything formal
uh but just to give you a flavor of
what's going on here
so the idea is actually relatively
simple so if you see on the bottom left
of the screen what i'm doing here is i'm
just partitioning the truth table
of the circuit scheme and
i'm assigning a subcircuit ci
to compute the ith block of the truth
table
of the circuit c the exact
exact number of blocks is not not really
relevant but
let's just imagine that um that is
that they are just enough blocks for
this transformation to work and the idea
is very simple
i'm going to sample a unique crs and i'm
going to use it
uh i'm going to reuse it across all
instances of the xio
where each instance of the xio is used
to obfuscate its sub-circuit
ci okay so the the crs is going to be um
is going to be reused across all the
instances well now
uh this gives me at least a
syntactically correct xio
and now the point is that if you analyze
the size of the crs
the crs will only grow with the truth
table of a sub-circuit which is
sub-linear
in the size of the total truth table of
c so
what i can do i can just take this here
and sample it locally
and attach it basically hardwired with
the description
of the obfuscated circuit c so i can
just add it to the observation of the
circuit c so which is makes it in the
plane model and the security is actually
a very simple argument
i can maybe one way to say it is that
if you were if you had to say an
x x i o with a a c o s of size n to the
hundred
that uh save the factor of n to the
epsilon
then now uh you can convert it in a c or
into something that doesn't use in cos
at all but uh saves a factor of n to the
epsilon over 100 or something like that
yeah something like that like the exact
constants are
are not important right so as long as
it's uh
as it's in the exponent we're okay with
this so yes
um right so so to see that
that this the scheme is actually secure
it is actually pretty easy
uh you you basically uh do um do a
switch
to each circuit so let's say i have a
circuit c prime which is functional
equivalent to my circuit
i basically i'm basically going to do a
switch element by element from
uh by programming the crs whenever
and this gives me essentially
essentially the security that i want
right um okay i hope this is clear
um you shouldn't you shouldn't the
parameter shouldn't be clear from this
explanation just give you really giving
you an intuitive
explanation of how things things are
done so
let's let's just assume that we're going
to have a crs since we know we can
anyway remove it generically
and our tool our tool that we're going
to introduce in this work
is going to be split fh uh and you might
you might have heard the notion
functional encoding which has been
mentioned a few times
um in this work and has been introduced
in the work of
wix and we and you should think of
functional encoding as just a more
general
version of split fv so they essentially
abstract away some of the algorithms and
give
this more general notion but for the
purpose of this thought we're just going
to work with the split fhe just for
for conceptual simplicity so what is
split efficient so first of all split
fhe also
includes the crs so it's also in the crs
model and it is a standard fhe scheme in
the sense that
i can i can encrypt messages and compute
functions over the messages to obtain
ciphertext that encrypt the output of
the computation
so this is so far is uh is just
identical to fhe
so the um the the new algorithm that we
have
is a is what i call him computational
algorithm so
in short the hint algorithm that takes
his input a secret key
a given cipher text c that encrypts a
certain message from
and compute a hint so the hint depends
on the secret key on
and in particular will be some function
of the randomness of this specific
ciphertext
and by itself the hint is sufficient to
reveal
the content of the ciphertext for the
case of this specific example
we will reveal f of n now so uh wait
so the the hint takes his input the
secret ken it takes his input the cipher
text not the randomness right
not the randomness no no of course i
mean uh yeah for for
many instantiation you can recover the
randomness of fhe
uh but yeah it doesn't matter like
it just really takes text input on the
secret key
um good so
so of course you this by itself this
definition is not very meaningful i need
to
impose a little bit more constraint on
this
on this decryption hint so first of all
i need to make sure that this hint does
not reveal
anything besides that for them because
otherwise i could just set the him to be
the secret key of the scheme so that's
not helpful
right i just want to make sure it's
going to compute some information that
just
allows me to decrypt one specific
ciphertext and not
all possible ciphertext
and the maybe more tricky requirement
that i'm going to also impose is that of
the size of the hinge so the size of the
hint
should be um much smaller and
particularly
sublinear in the size of the plain text
of the so
this is essentially since since people
are really acquainted with
with the notion of io and if you need
some sort of compression
this is essentially where the
compression will come from so you're
going to release
instead of releasing the full alphabet
you're going to release some hint
that will allow anyone giving this hint
and the cypher text to recover iphone
okay so um yes
one way to think about this is like a
functional hint
right in the sense that like just like
how a functional key
restricts you to the function in this
sense it's like a
a functional hint that restricts you
both to the cert to the ciphertext and
to the uh yeah right
perfect perfectly correct and so maybe
maybe
this should be it should be uh you know
also
i should also mention that uh maybe this
this uh
this connection is more clear with the
notion of functional encoding where
you compute a hint with respect to to a
function
and it doesn't really functional encode
it doesn't really say
how this function is computed in this
case we
sort of impose the structural constraint
that this function is going to be
homomorphic evaluation over a certain
science
right so yeah you know i have a question
though so i'm a little confused about
the size of the hint
for example if the fhq's identity you
know it's just
m in the hand so
i don't want to think of it as a
functional i just want to think you know
you have encryption of a message
and i give you a small hint that allows
me to decrypt the message
yes so and the size of that in it will
be
sublinear in the size of that message
maybe maybe a different way of saying it
is that the size of the hint is going to
be independent of the size of f of m so
for maybe for short messages it can be
like the hint is not going to be very
useful but at least if you if you
evaluate functions with long enough
output
then uh then you're going to get this
condition that it's going to be smaller
than f of m
is all right i mean uh yeah that that's
that's something
is just like more like what was running
out earlier
shouldn't we think of it as like the
size of the hint is like poly m
comma size of f of m isn't that enough
um no the hints uh if i made i'm in the
uh in order to to obtain f of m
you need both the cipher text and the
hint
so the the the cipher text is is is big
but the the hint is tiny so
i just talked about m just m itself
m can be small right
uh yeah and can be small but so even in
the specific picture
just clarify the discussion are we
talking about what is needed or what
is achievable no here my question was
the following
and why is it the way it's stated it's
not clear to me why there is even a
function there the way
the way it stated seems like the way to
state is just say look i'm giving you an
fhe
u of m and you can find m
via a hint and the hint is going to be
of size that depends only of the secret
key
but not of m that's kind of what seems
to be written here
but you wanted to apply also to
post-evaluated cipher text
okay what you said it doesn't follow
that it works also for post-evaluating
i guess the point maybe is that there is
the following trivial condition if you
didn't require the encryption to be
a fully homomorphic and that is the
following so suppose you
every every cipher text every plain text
you encrypt
you create a short a
ad hockey and you
you basically send an encryption of that
key plus an encryption of the message
say with respect to that key
now the in the hint can be the this
short ad-hoc key
and and that would satisfy everything
except this is not a an [ __ ]
an ideal split not fhe like an
encryption scheme that's not fhe is a
hybrid encryption scheme
so we want like something that sort of
behaves like a hybrid encryption scheme
but it's also an fhe also supports some
morphic evaluation right julio
uh so yeah i mean uh i'm not sure
what i'm supposed to comment on maybe
just to give a little more intuition for
people
the way it's used is you can encrypt one
message but evaluate many functions over
it and release many hints for that same
message maybe that'll
help clarify what's next okay yeah so
confirm my question which was just that
is it sufficient
to have the property the size of the
hint is
polynomial in m but then you know
uh much smaller than f than the size of
f of m i believe the answer is yes but
yeah yeah i i'm sure the answer is yes
yes very good
so um so i guess
on a different side like
in um of security um do you require
like i will require that the hinge
shouldn't give me
more information on other ciphertexts
like i understand that in terms of
functionality you need
him to be tailored you allow the hint to
be tailored for the psychotics
but is it also a security restriction
uh yeah yes it is so like yeah you don't
want to say it
formally because it's a bit messy but um
formally we're really going to require
simulation security and that's going to
be only achievable in the crs model
so we're really going to say that uh
if you have control over the crs and i
give you a certain plain text for
for that you want to program over at the
ciphertext then
given you know a trapdoor for the crs or
given a control over the crs you can
compute a hint that corresponds to that
specific message
so the security in a simulation sense
sorry i want to make sure this is i
understand this because it's important
it's what amit said is seems
much weaker than what is written here
which i agree with
i mean i see that's what you need that's
what confused me here because
you don't need to compress m that's kind
of the point you just need to compress
you know you don't want to depend on the
output size but there's no compression
of m
in this in the hint good so so i think
like one
one maybe confusion is as vegan we're
saying before is what we need versus
what we actually achieve
right so i mean it was asking whether it
would be sufficient
whether the size of the hint could
depend on n but not on f of n
but which the answer is yes but what we
actually achieve is that
you can forget about all computations
just give me a large fhe ciphertext and
i can compute a hint
of size independent of the underlying
plaintext so that's what we actually
achieve
maybe it's an overkill but that's what
we achieve
does that answer your question one more
question
maybe it's trivial but the hint
algorithm
should be oblivious of the function
right
um so you're you're saying just takes as
input
any cipher text then yes so if the fh is
circuit private
it will be obvious of the functions you
can define
but so so if the so it's okay to have a
function an fhe which is not circuit
private and to let the hint
run in time that depends on the function
as long as the output is sufficiently
short
it would be okay yes um that's something
so we achieved
so what what you said before sorry what
what i defined here
uh it's slightly stronger than what you
say so but
what you say is very insufficient for io
so so
another question the effigy and
encryption
can be randomized so in principle
could you do something like create a
session key
right so so a cipher text look like say
an encryption of a symmetric key and an
encryption of a
an an a and an encryption of the true
message with respect to the symmetric
key and then you do maybe everything
homomorphically uh you
uh but i guess you want to uh
yeah i guess you don't have to see the
encryption under the symmetric key in
the clear so that would maybe
or maybe you do okay we'll see what what
happens but uh
yeah very clear very close indeed to
hybrid encryption
boss i think i think i sort of i think
your intuition is correct right hybrid
encryption is what we're shooting for
but you want it to work also for
post-evaluated cipher text right
if we could i mean this is sort of
related and this is uh also historically
related
to trying to get a fully homomorphic
encryption where the post-evaluated
ciphertext has a good uh information
rate
so you know the best information rate
that you can hope for is achieved by
uh uh by hybrid encryption right there
you have like an almost uh
additive the rate is one even even by
with an additive term
so you know uh this is uh so if you
could do it for an and also and also
here if you could
sort of have a homomorphic encryption
scheme where the post-evaluated
ciphertext also
kind of behaves like a hybrid encryption
then that would be
a good thing both for the question of of
achieving good rate
and also for obtaining a hint here
because sort of the hint is going to be
uh sort of the the chem key and sort of
you still need to worry about privacy
but it's sort of in the same sense that
that judo is going to the julius is
talking about here okay
but why can't you just always decree
homomo the cryptomorphically one day
uh i guess the re-encrypts would be a
problem because you're in
cryptomorphically and you want the
re-encryption to be
a encryption under the private key
scheme okay i i think i understand thank
you
i'm sorry yeah the properties that you
want the
uh the chem key to be sort of completely
fresh
every time you evaluate right that's
really the that's this functional aspect
of the hint
that's the security that's the security
aspect you don't need to be fresh right
but you don't want it to leak
information
and i think it's really a good intuition
to keep in mind when uh when we
when we see the constructions uh
actually maybe we can let him continue
and see him
maybe if we're lucky maybe we'll even
get it
okay i think i'm getting okay
yeah um good so um
[Music]
okay so yeah uh as we already said by
the way like
i think an interesting aspect of this
work is that uh
historically what we were interested in
was actually to a good rate
fhe rather than rather than i o and then
we just start exploring start
from that structure anyway so
uh let's uh let's see how split fhe is
sufficient to construct
xio and i'm going to first show a
simplified construction of that
um and it's going to be pretty intuitive
and
then i'm going to show maybe a slightly
less simplified but still
quite quite simple construction so the
idea is relatively simple
so um you just uh the obfuscator circuit
consists
as an fha encryption of a circuit c um
and then the obfuscator evaluate this
this encryption automorphically over all
possible inputs and recall that
i'm just doing xio um and um
i can iterate over all possible inputs
of the ciphertext c so this essentially
gives me
uh an encryption of all possible values
of the circuit c on all possible inputs
which is basically the through table
of the circuit c okay so and now now
what i do is
i take this encryption uh use the secret
key
to compute the hint for this encryption
and that's
essentially it so this is basically my
obfuscation
so my obfuscation will consist of the
encryption of c
together with a hint computed over the
cipher text that contain the truth table
of the circuit uh displacement
obfuscation
and well we know that the
size of the encryption can grow at most
polynomially with respect to the size of
the description of c
and the size of the hint will also be
sublinear in the truth table of c
which gives you the compression that we
want for example
again ignoring ignoring some
some factors in polynomial factors in
the security parameters
okay so this is the uh this is the
obfuscated circuit
and what we do in order to evaluate the
circuit well
it's actually rather natural so given an
encryption of c
i can again repeat the process of
evaluating the encryption over all
possible circuits
and keep in mind that the fha evaluation
procedure
is a deterministic operation so if i
evaluate
over the same function i will obtain
exactly the same ciphertext which
contains the truth table of c
now given the hint that was given to me
during the
during the obfuscation i can basically
expand
and recover the truth table of c okay
so this is it um unfortunately
things are not super not so simple but
that fortunately they're not that
complicated either so here i
is kind of swipe under the rug the fact
that the size of the public key
might be proportional to the size of the
output
of the function in particular the
maximum size of the
text that we can fit inside of one fhe
cipher text
might affect the size of the public key
as well
so that seems to be a problem because
now i have to also include the public
key
in the obfuscated circuit and this
essentially kills all the compression
um fortunately the idea the idea that
that essentially saves us is the fact
that
the public key is reusable so
so the idea is to amortize the size of
the public key over several executions
sorry can you julia i i missed that
why why would the public key depend on
the
on ffm i mean this is fhe right so
um so you have to define a plain text
space
for even for fhe right yeah
and the size of the public key might
depend on that plain text space
but but why would the plain text space
depend on f
first first you choose a a you know an
[ __ ] whatever you choose and only then
comes f right so
so okay so here's uh i mean you can
think of fhe just encrypting beats right
yeah exactly um but that's not how we
should think of it because that
doesn't allow us to compute short hints
so
we you should really think of fhe as a
as a as having a certain fixed
plaintext space you can fit so many bits
of information inside of that plain text
space
and my hint will allow me to recover
those those bits fitted in that in that
specific space and
the space is somewhat defined by the
public key as well
but how does that depend on f why does
that depend on f
oh it doesn't depend on f is the size of
f so it's
the size of the output of the of the
function right so the size of uh
maybe the natural definition for i'm
guessing that
you know the natural definition would
say that the publicly should just be a
size of the security parameter and
should be independent of the size of the
plaintext but i'm guessing that their
construction
actually does have long public keys so
they need it exactly
so so if you think of it abstractly we
the size of the public he should have
been the poly security parameter but
this is i guess the difference between
what you want and what you get and then
so but this is basically
we have seen before right if you have a
reusable quantity then you don't really
care about it
precisely precisely so this is exactly
the same trick as before
but the public key is not going to be as
reusable as the crs
so this is something if you can improve
it then you will somehow improve the
parameters of the xio scheme that you
get in the end
um i mean you can get io from any xio
scheme but
still um yeah i guess
i guess here i guess here maybe maybe
one i can comment on this and say that
that actually creates us a lot of
problems so if you if you would have a
public key
um which would be completely independent
of the size of this plain text
space then i suspect we would we could
even give like
a proof against even a better assumption
it seems like the main difference there
is if you had a short public key
you could like in the construction you
gave earlier the simplified one
you only need one opening one hand
exactly exactly
here because you need to use the same
public key for many many times you need
it to be reusable you need security for
many hands and that's besides the
issue precisely and then you know like
the
the
i mean looking ahead there might be some
leakage for each hint and then if you
have only one hint you could you know
like
hope for some leakage resilience or
something like this but yeah
and for for many hints the things become
more complicated
yeah that's exactly i mean i don't you
shouldn't be clear
at this moment um so
here i want to spend a few minutes on
explain how to build
uh split efficiency how much time do i
have left
probably zero minutes uh i i think the
the next three hours
uh is next three talks are basically all
coordinated and we do have a very
hard boundary with daniel because
otherwise we get in trouble with god and
we don't want that
so
i mean i think we can um it would be
nice if you can
finish in 20 minutes let's say so that
would be like finishing
10 30 instead of the original thing 10
10 er sorry
it would be even even nicer if you can
so it would actually be nice if you can
finish in
15 minutes and and then
and then maybe we could go straight to
the second part i think
crypto people are tough we can handle uh
two talks back to back
okay i'll i'll i'll try to be quick but
precise
uh and but but still feel free to
interrupt me i think it's good if the
discussion happens nevertheless
if if not i'll just upload this line and
you can see them they're not very
insightful anyway
good so uh here i want to i want to
explain how to get this
uh this uh how to get this notion of
split fh so we're now going to construct
with fh and i'm going to really just
give a very modular construction
and you'll see that the ideas here are
very general so they're not going to
talk about algebraic structure i'm not
going to talk about any
any specific assumption i'm just really
going to talk about encryption schemes
and it and i hope that that that these
ideas
are like should be pretty portable even
to other contexts so
um so far i haven't found any other
application but you know
maybe you can find one um so let's
consider a simple but flawed attempt to
construct splitter feature
so we're going to start from two
building blocks so the first building
blocks on the left is going to be a
fully homework encryption
with almost linear decryption what does
it mean almost linear
we've seen this already in this in this
workshop but
basically means that the decryption
circuit consists of a linear function
over over some some modules
followed by a rounding operation so it's
linear plus run
on the right side we have a public
encryption which satisfies only limited
notion of homomorphism specifically
linear homomorphism and for which we can
define
the notion of small encryption here so
i'm not going to talk about how to
define that this is more of a structural
property of this public
encryption uh but if you're interested
you should you should look at the paper
and roman and daniel will talk
about specific instantiation length all
i'm going to mention is that in the
original
btg m20 work this scheme was the
downgrade during encryption scheme
whereas in the follow-up work uh we
somehow managed to
lift that to the lattice settings and we
gave a packed variant of dual record
for which we can define a notion this
notion of small hints
and i really i don't want to to say
anything more about this and if you have
questions about specific instantiation
then please hold them until you see the
talk of roman and daniel
um so so i'm just going to take this to
building blocks so i'm going to
construct splitter feature
well it's actually pretty simple the
idea i'm going to start with an fhe
encryption of a circuit c
and as before evaluate it over all
possible inputs and compute
the truth table of of the circuit
once i have the truth table which is
going to be the message that i'm
interested in
i'm going to key switch in this public
key encryption so what does it mean to
key switch
it essentially means to evaluate the
decryption circuit homomorphically
now i cannot evaluate the full
decryption circuit homomorphically
i can only evaluate the linear part of
operation
of the decryption circuit so what i'm
going to end up with
is going to be and some encoding of the
of the message which is the truth table
of c
plus some noise okay
[Music]
and the naive idea would be okay since
this uh public encryption has small
hints
let's just release the hint for such a
cipher text
and this would reveal my encoding of the
truth table plus noise if i encode
things properly the noise doesn't create
correctness problems because i can
round it away of course this this stand
is completely flawed i'm sure
all of you by now figured why and the
problem is that the noise turn
cannot be disclosed and in particular uh
as daniel
also also commented before if the the
the the fact that the exile will uh
sorry that our spirit fsg will allow us
to recover multiple noise will
essentially
uh cause a complete breakdown of the of
the scheme because
we're essentially going to be able to to
recover the security of the scheme in
polynomial time
by a simple linear algebra so this is
this is not good
um yeah you can hear a little bit the
abstraction barrier
uh in some sense we should forget about
you're still talking about circuits and
truth tables but we should forget about
roof tables and circuits at this point
right you just said basics is saying
uh you have an arbitrary cipher text and
what you're doing is you're uh
sending out the cipher you know you said
you're appending to the cipher text of a
according to the full homomorphic
encryption also the cipher text
that encodes the
um the that does have half
half of the way towards decryption uh so
so you encrypt the secret key of the
fully automatic encryption
with the other encryption and then you
get halfway towards the
decryption but right now you have like
this hint that if you if you really
reveal too much right
right right so this is just to draw an
analogy to the to the x zero settings
but yeah
in principle of course you you should
forget about c and through table of c
you can just be
we can just be any message m right so we
can just write here any message m
we evaluate some function f and this
consists of f of n
and of course the same logic applies
besides the fact that now we reveal f of
n instead of the truth table of c
i hope that that clarifies yeah yeah
sorry so i understand that you go to
the uh linear uh part like a boss that
have decryption but then
what what is the hint yeah as i said
i'm not going to talk how to compute the
hint okay okay you're assuming there's a
hint that allows you to do that okay
yeah exactly and just i'm just
abstracting that away and you have to be
a little patient
and wait for the next talk and then
we'll see exactly what
the hint is going to be yeah yeah
sorry for the confusion um
okay so of course this is this creates
security problems
um and now we're going to assume that
we're going to live in an idealized
world so let's let's see what would be
the ideal solution
so now i'm going to assume that the crs
magically consists
of many encryptions of this public key
encryption
of some terms s where s is something
which is
small and random okay so let's forget
about the exact parameters
i'm going to use s to be small enough
but large enough so
s is going to be of a dimension that
will fit my needs later
but let's see how to how to uh correct
the previous
paradigm in order to get something which
is secure at least
in this ideal world okay so the scheme
proceeds as before
um i'm going to again compute the
the the the evaluation of the truth
table or the function that i want over
the homomorphic encryption
uh key switch into the public key
encryption
and now the the the only difference that
with respect to the previous scheme is
that
before releasing the hint i'm going to
homomorphically add
uh this public encryption of this small
randomness
s so what this gives me is basically a
public key encryption
record that this is linearly homomorphic
and this is a sum and
i can evaluate it this is going to be to
give me a public encryption
of an encoded version of a truth table
plus the noise plus
s and now if i set my parameters
correctly then
s is going to smudge out the noise
and the resulting term is going to be a
uniform
a uniform uniformly distributed string
so now it's really cautious on my side
to
take the result in public key encryption
sorry exactly ciphertext
here and release a decryption hint for
such a ciphertext so
and and this you can you can easily see
that
the security is not ruined because of a
standard magic argument
okay so you only get weak
indistinguishability like that's
related to how big is the crs um yeah
i'm not going to talk about uh
uh about security here but no you can
actually program the crs to get
simulation security here
um if you if you instead of putting
i mean quantitatively like the the
amount of smudging is it the case that
it's only one of the polynomial
industries no no no no no no good good
so that's a statistical smudging so
recall that we are all
we are in the lattice world so we can uh
we don't need to compute any discrete
logarithm here so we can have a really
large
smudging noise um we can do it really do
statistical
matching so we don't have
the the the issue of uh amplifying the
the security of the scheme
and by the way even for for danger
during encryption
one difference one crucial difference
with respect to the framework of jls
that we saw yesterday
is even in those settings we can also do
uh
uh quote-unquote proper
smudging noise so we of course so we
don't have to go
over this amplification steps
okay so good so this is fantastic well
the
problem is of course that the public key
encryption of something small
is not really uniformly distributed okay
and in particular this
uh this would require me to to uh to
give some
some of this information i cannot just
like hope that the crs will magically
empty structure
okay so what do we do so here is the
last
uh the the last slide so and and and and
our actual solution so the
the general blueprint of our solution so
now i'm going to assume
that uh my crs is going to consist
of uh public key encryptions of
string s where s is just random so i'm
not assuming it is small i'm just
assuming that this unit is
uniformly distributed and let's pretend
for the moment that this is possible of
course this is only possible
if this public encryption scheme has the
so-called dense ciphertext so that means
that
a uniform string is going to be a part
of the ciphertext space
with overwhelming probability but let's
assume now that our public encryption
satisfies this notion okay
so i'm going to i'm going to assume this
and now the idea is very simple so the
idea is
now if we try to apply the previous
previous approach this term s will not
only smudge the noise will also smash my
uh my plaintext so it will introduce too
much randomness inside of the
public encryption and it is is
let's first um let's somehow
include this uh site this
information s and in particular only the
high order bits of s inside of the
computations
in such a way that the the information
of
s that is going to cancel out the
message
will be preemptively subtracted away
from the fhe computation so i'm going to
be a little bit more precise now
so what am i going to do so the first
the first modification
is that not only i'm going to publish a
public key encryption
of the secret key of the fhe but i'm
also going to publish
an fhe encryption of the secret key of
the public key encryption
um and here is where the you can already
see where the the
circular dependency comes from actually
the assumption is more complicated than
that so
this is it's not like just uh security
in the presence of this cycle is a
little bit more complicated than that
but i don't want to talk about this now
it will be the next talk
so um so this
this additional uh fh encryption of the
public key
will allow me to homomorphically
evaluate this circuit
here on the left which i call pi and pi
will essentially compute as before
the truth table of c so my evaluated my
evaluated message
minus z where z are just the higher
order bits of s
so note that i have the secret key of
the public key encryption scheme so i
can
decrypt this ciphertext in the crs
recover s
and just throw away the lower order bits
of s okay
uh julio sorry i have a question i
didn't understand what was the problem
before
so what if the encryption so before you
said let's encrypt encrypt a bigger
smudging noise that will smudge away
you said that the promise that the
cipher text is not random
yeah so the problem is that this
ciphertext that you want to include in
the crs
has too much structure so the crs will
not be uniformly sampled
but why does it need to be what's wrong
that it has a structure
maybe maybe it's important it's
important that the crs can be generated
without any secret information right
and even without depending on the public
key because it has to be reused across
different instances of the xio
so the the distribution of the crs
should not depend on the public key
right so in this case it shows your
usability
that's the issue exactly the issue is it
precisely ready
um okay
yeah maybe i think it's a good moment to
ask question if you if you
um it's still like somehow if it was
just uh trying to say if
if uh if it was a for example
a bit by bit encryption but you still
think of the domain as
being large then you could hope that you
could get a a random
power you know a random small noise by
simply uh
taking things from the crs which will be
the lower the bits and then the higher
order bits would be zero or something
like that right so
so it's not that it's inherently uh in
so so it's not that there is no chance
at all to
have the crs be uh be
random small things it's just that we
don't you don't know of a construction
that will do that right
yeah precisely so in particular if there
was a way to obliviously sample
uh public encryptions of small values
for some definition of small for some
public encryption
then you might have some leverage here
right so the the question the point is
that for all
uh constructions that i know at least
this seems difficult to do that
i guess another thing you could have
done is if if you
encryption was a little bit more
homomorphic than linear
potentially you could have some
transformation that somehow
takes a random thing and maps it into
something small like say
you know if you multiply these two ones
then it becomes a
zero with higher probability or
something similar so you could
uh potentially homomorphically
make something that's random into
something that's smaller or something
like that
yeah i mean if if that was a fully
homomorphic encryption scheme for for
which you could define small hints then
that would be definitely an approach i
mean i'm not sure what would go wrong
but i would have to look at the scheme
at least
but sort of boss what you're suggesting
is just sort of yeah different ways of
like sort of taking crf which is
a random encryption something random and
turned to an encryption of something
small right
so it was describing the way that uh
you know we we came up with uh but but
you could definitely like it's
it's a good idea to try to think about
maybe maybe other ways of of doing it
no it's interesting because that's the
only
i mean it's really beautiful but that's
the only part where you use circularity
right so it doesn't seem like
circularity is such an essential thing
part of of this construction because the
it's it seems to be getting around a
very technical specific issue
that potentially for example if this was
instead of the
linearizer maybe degree five or whatever
there might be some very
small limited amount of homomorphism in
the par
in the encryption thing that would have
been enough
yeah i mean it's hard to say whether
this is really inherent or not
uh yeah i i somehow the same feeling
that
uh it's really more due to a
technicality rather than some
some like i don't know inner working of
of natures that that's happening here so
yeah that makes should make us hopeful
then to improve this soon
um but yeah for the moment at least i
don't know how to
uh how to sample things uh also sample
yeah
uh this disciples which are inherently
sparse right the system is the message
space is large that this is definitely
a sparse cypher as far as subset of the
of the whole space
so we're going to to to have to to to do
with this uh
with this circularity and again let me
repeat it so that
what i really want to really care in the
end is to just get an fhu encryption on
the truth table of c
so the output that i care about minus
set again the high order bits of
s now as before i can key switch
into the public key encryption and now
note that
differently from before i had this
additional term minus set
due to the different computations i
performed so up to now i've just changed
the
homomorphic computation like the formula
on the left and now
i can simply uh add the uh
encryption of uh of s which which i
find it from the crs and well note that
that s minus z is going to cancel out
the high order bits of
s so i'm going to end up with something
uh which are essentially uh the low
order bits
of s and for the same analysis as before
um this lower the b2s by
again setting the parameters
appropriately um
uh they are going to smudge out the
noise the decryption noise of the fhe
which
i denoted here by noise and now
supposedly it's cautious to
just release the input describing the
decryption hint for the resulting
ciphertext
now um you have to be a little careful
because in this
this is a pretty sloppy analysis and in
particular this assumes that
the decryption noise of the fhe is
completely independent uh from uh uh
from from s which might not be
uh so you have to you have to
because the reason is because i'm
evaluating uh homomorphic decryption of
s so
s is in some sense entering into the
inner working of the fhe so
you cannot prove it with this analysis
um but this is essentially the backbone
of all the schemes that you're going to
see today
um and this is if you want to think of
it as a
as a heuristic you should you can think
of this as like the
the main working of of that that
basically is a is a common denominator
of all these approaches
and they are going to be like very
clever techniques in order
that they have been developed in order
to
prove this uh this heuristic against uh
against good assumptions or like the
simple assumptions
okay that's actually all i wanted to say
and
there have been a lot of questions but
i'm happy to take more i'm not sure if
we have time
but yeah thanks for your attention maybe
people can
ask questions while
roman shows his screen so
we can also see your face that's uh
fantastic
you do exist you're not a super ai that
was created by the other co-authors
can i ask a question that's uh slightly
not related but just uh we can talk it
later i see oh man was fast
but uh um that was a question that
someone asked me
yesterday and uh i'm asking it back
which is
uh xio you know how how
how much can we push it so can we really
is it
n to the one minus epsilon or can we
even go below
do we know if we can go below that yeah
i think i think sanjon has this work
that shows that
uh even one bit more is sufficient right
so you get one with compressions
that's for a fee but i'm not sure if
that's for xio the same thing extends
but it's it might be plausible
uh if i had to bet money i would say
maybe it's doable but i don't know
okay yeah that was my question it'd be
nice to know
yeah so when we're doing the original
analysis we needed this entire one uh
one minus epsilon for some annoying
reasons
but maybe with the new techniques in san
juan's paper it can be improved
because to analyze xco it's not just
exponential hybrid it's actually
you need to rely on the fact that you're
applying this construction iteratively
you actually have it's not just the
distinguishes running time actually
increases also so it's not just a
distinguishability gap that uh
that needs to be small okay so maybe
yeah yeah maybe there are issues that i
haven't thought about xio
just for the fp case it does but yeah
thanks
yes and let's continue to the next
next step
with the